Our discussion of knowledge-based
agents in this CS7637 class is
organized around seven principals.
Be on the lookout for the seven
principals, they'll occur again and
again throughout the course.
Principal number one, agents use
knowledge to guide reasoning and
they represent and organize this
knowledge into knowledge structures.
Principle number two,
learning is often incremental.
This connects back to one of
the characteristics of problems,
where data and
experience was coming incrementally.
Number three, reasoning is
top down not just bottom up.
We just don't reason from data,
we also use data to pull
out knowledge from memory,
then we use this knowledge to generate
expectations to make sense of the world.
Principle number four, knowledge-based
AI agents match methods to tasks.
We'll discuss a number
of different methods.
We'll also discuss several tasks.
Later, we'll discuss how AI agents
can select specific methods to
address particular tasks and
even integrate different methods
to address complex tasks.
Principle number five,
agents use heuristics to find
solutions that are good enough.
They do not necessarily
find optimal solutions.
This is because of a trade off
between computer efficiency and
the optimality of solutions.
Our focus will be on using
bounded rationality and yet,
giving near real-time time performance
on [INAUDIBLE] intractable problems.
This happens,
because agents use heuristics to find
solutions that are just good enough.
Principle number six,
agents make use of recurring
patterns of problems in the world.
Of course,
there are a number of problems.
But even this number of problems are
characterized the patterns that occur
again and again.
Number seven, reasoning, learning and
memory constrain and support each other.
We'll build theories that are not
just theories of reasoning or
theories of learning or theories of
memory, but we'll build theories that
unify the three of them into
one single cognitive system.
These principles will come again and
again in this particular class.
So we highly recommend that you
take a moment, pause the video and
read over the principles once again.